[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction horror film
called splice
spoilers ahead watch out and take
[Music]
care clive nicole and elsa cast are a
genetic engineer couple working for a
company called nucleic exchange research
and development or nerd their primary
job at the company is to conduct
research on splicing several animals dna
to create hybrid creatures with unique
qualities the company's aim is to use
the unique compounds found in the
hybrid's body to create medicines that
can treat most of the diseases in the
world at the beginning of the movie we
see clive and elsa bring out a
successful hybrid male creature they
name the creature fred and put him with
their previous successful female
creature named ginger everyone watches
in fascination as fred and ginger meet
for the first time and create a
ball-like shape with their tongues to
greet each other
later clive and elsa are in a meeting
with the ceo of the company joan sharat
joan is delighted with the result of
their experiment and wants to start
extracting genetic materials that will
help them create medicines immediately
the couple puts forward an idea of
forming a human hybrid since that will
give them many more varieties of
compounds to choose from using such
compounds diseases like alzheimer's
parkinson's and even some forms of
cancer can be treated however joan wants
to focus on the existing hybrids for the
moment elsa insists that if they don't
do it first someone else will but the
ceo is adamant about her decision the
couple comes out of the meeting
disheartened and angry however they do
not plan to back down
since the company won't allow them to
conduct the experiment they decide to do
it on their own
what could possibly go wrong at the lab
elsa gets human dna from a random donor
and the two start to experiment splicing
it with animal's dna as they did with
fred and ginger when they fail to match
the dna for the first couple of tries
elsa suggests they bring out another
person's dna and continue the experiment
she hands clive a sample claiming that
it is the best human dna she could find
the two finally get the temperature
right and the splicing is successful now
they will have to incubate the cell and
allow it to develop into a fetus but
since human cloning is illegal and is
considered highly unethical in genetic
engineering clive wants to stop the
experiment elsa however insists they
continue just to see if the splicing was
actually successful she insists that the
experiment will be controlled so it
won't matter even if they fail clive
obliges and puts the cells in an
incubator the couple watches as the
cells begin to multiply rapidly the
following morning elsa checks to see how
much the creature has developed and is
surprised to see it developing at an
exponential rate later the couple is at
their home when they get an emergency
message from the lab they rush there to
see the fetus has developed fully way
earlier than its due date the two break
the incubator and a slimy creature falls
to the ground they leave after putting
the creature in a safe place the next
morning clive tells elsa that they have
to kill the fetus because it can be
dangerous elsa doesn't want to kill it
just yet but knows that they will be in
huge trouble if anyone finds out about
the creature the couple goes to the lab
only to find the creature is already
dead when elsa opens the cell she sees
it is just the outer skin of the
creature meaning that the creature is
alive and somewhere near
just then it screeches from the ceiling
clive from outside asks elsa to get out
so they can fill the room with poisonous
gas and kill the creature but elsa does
the opposite and opens out her hand to
the newborn calling it to her just then
clive comes in scaring the creature the
couple leaves the room and knocks the
creature out using a gas after examining
it they find out that she is a female
and is growing rapidly at this rate she
will be dead in months so they plan to
make the best of the time she has and
observe her instead of killing her the
x-rays show a tumor inside her body
which the couple is confused about the
creature also has a sharp venomous tail
that she uses for her defense it is now
a week after the creature was born clive
tries to feed her but she doesn't
cooperate the couple soon figures out
that she only likes sweet food which
makes it easier for them to feed her
elsa starts treating the little girl as
her own child she dresses her up and
teaches the creature to spell her name
the little creature spells the word nerd
copying the words on elsa's shirt elsa
is surprised by her intelligence and
names the girl jiren an anagram of nerd
just then clive arrives and accuses elsa
of treating dren like a pet they begin
to argue loudly which is heard by
clive's brother gavin who also works at
nerd he sneaks into their lab and is
attacked by dren elsa scolds the girl
and asks her to go away clive tries to
explain the situation to gavin who is
pissed off about them doing an illegal
experiment the couple knows that they
cannot keep dren in the lab anymore so
they bring her to the basement of the
facility when they reach there the
creature gets a fever and stops
breathing clive puts her into a cold
bath and the couple realized that dren's
tumor was actually an amphibian lung so
she can breathe underwater as well the
time comes when the couple has to
present ginger and fred to the media at
a conference they present the creatures
together but the conference soon turns
into chaos when the creatures begin to
fight each other creating a bloodbath
later clive and elsa brief what went
wrong to the ceo joan it turns out that
ginger has somehow changed her sex and
turned into a male so the tension
between the two males caused them to
fight the couple had been so busy with
dren that they didn't even notice when
ginger changed her gender due to all of
this joan orders them to stop all the
splicing processes and somehow
synthesize the protein they need at any
cost the whole facility will be taken
over in a few days so dren has to be
taken somewhere safe the couple planned
to take her to elsa's mother's old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere that
way dren can be safe and can have more
freedom later elsa and clive bring dren
to the barn but she runs away scared the
duo finds her devouring a rabbit nearby
and takes her inside elsa scolds a
visibly sad dren making her jump into a
water tank clive believes she needs to
be alone for a while so the two work on
cleaning the place for her at night
draen refuses to eat and makes the words
tedious and outside with the alphabet
claiming that she is bored and wants to
go outside when elsa says she cannot do
that dren gets aggressive and runs
outside through the skylight window the
couple climbs up to the roof to see that
she has grown wings and is about to fly
away clive calls her back claiming that
he loves her hearing this dren hugs him
and agrees to go inside again the next
day elsa and dran are together when elsa
finds pictures of clive that dren has
drawn she is starting to develop
feelings for him just then dren finds a
cat and plays with it but elsa takes it
from her fearing that she will kill it
as well clive comes home to a sad dren
and dances with her to make her happy
while dancing he suddenly realizes that
elsa used her own dna to create dren
clive angrily confronts elsa for putting
herself into the experiment but elsa
dismisses the matter claiming that they
have come too far to talk about that now
the next day elsa brings a cat to dren
as a gift thinking that she should get a
chance to have more friends but to her
surprise dren kills the cat with her
tail and attacks elsa as well a
surprised elsa lies on the ground as
dren takes the keys from her and opens
the door but before she can run away
elsa knocks her out and ties her to a
table fed up with dren she has decided
to cut her tail so she won't be
dangerous to anyone anymore clive walks
in to find a naked dren lying tied on
the table with her tail cut off he feels
bad for the girl and frees her later he
is monitoring draen through cameras
fitted in her room he lovingly touches
her through the screen but stops once he
realizes what he is doing meanwhile elsa
is in the lab and has successfully
managed to create the protein using
venom from dren's tail she rushes to the
farmhouse to tell clive the good news
clive on the other hand walks into
dren's room and is greeted by dren who
kisses him he tries to retaliate but
eventually gives in and has intercourse
with the creature elsa walks into the
room and is horrified at the sight she
runs away angrily while clive follows
her apologizing later after having a
long conversation they finally decide to
kill dren and get rid of the problem
once and for all but when they return to
the farm they find her already on the
verge of death because of her being a
rapidly developing creature her lifetime
has ended the couple stays beside her as
she takes her last breath
elsa cries mourning the death of her
daughter-like creature heartbroken the
two bury the body outside just then
clive's brother gavin arrives with an
official from nerd they have found human
dna in the protein samples and are here
to see the creature elsa tells them that
she is dead but a loud screech is heard
just then it turns out that dren wasn't
dead after all she has changed into a
male like ginger did and has become
aggressive the male dren kills gavin and
his friend within seconds it drags clive
into a pond and then chases after elsa
soon elsa is caught by the male dren who
uses his regenerated sharp tail to tear
off her clothes and starts forcefully
mating with her some time later clive
comes to her aid and stabs dren with a
log it does the creature little to no
harm as he regenerates quickly draen is
about to kill clive when elsa bashes his
head with a rock she does it repeatedly
but stops midway pitying the creature
however dren takes the chance to strike
clive with his tail and kill him seeing
him kill her boyfriend elsa strikes the
creature several times and finally kills
him i think elsa will probably think
twice before building another snowman it
is now a few months after the incident
elsa sits with joan who offers her a
deal it turns out that elsa was
impregnated by dren and is bearing his
child jude wants to use the miracle
child to create medicines for the
betterment of mankind elsa accepts the
deal saying that she has nothing to lose
the movie proves how dangerous it is to
play with nature scientific inventions
and advancements should be done for
mankind's benefit but humans shouldn't
try to change the course of nature along
the way
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you